c'est un signe annonciateur de bonnes
nouvelles le chant des oiseaux est de
retour dans la forêt de rambouillet dans
ce camping la saison a débuté il ya
trois semaines déjà mais l'arrivée d'une
météo estivale marque le véritable
retour des clients on est rempli à 90%
sur nos locatifs pour ce week-end donc
c'est plutôt un très bon week-end et
ensuite bien évidemment il ya la partie
la partie camping qui va se remplir mais
avec moins de réservations ça puisse
être du passage qui va vraiment pour le
coup dépendre du soleil qui va être avec
nous ce week-end c'est toujours beaucoup
plus agréable et il est sûr que c'est un
impact important et dynamisant sur sur
les réservations au milieu des arbres et
en pleine nature l'offre de logements
est aussi variés qu original pour un
camping avec des cabanes et cahute
notamment 200 emplacements au total mais
une piscine encore en cours de
préparation pour les beaux jours
la piscine naturelle et non chauffés
donc nous demande d'attendre un petit
peu que l'eau chauffe aussi est ce qui
nous laisse un peu de temps pour
nettoyer pendant la saison le soleil est
quand même primordial il est toujours
plus compliqué d'aller se baigner sous
la pluie c'est une piscine non couvertes
les yvelinois seront sûrement nombreux à
vouloir profiter du week-end printanier
qui s'annonce si le camping de
rambouillet est déjà presque plein une
quinzaine d'autres sites dans les
yvelines offre une escapade entre la
nature et les chants des oiseaux